[MUSIC]
Neoliberalism is a term for the political and economic policies
associated with unrestrained free market global capitalism.
The term was popularized in the 1980s by Ronald Reagan, Margaret Thatcher,
and economist Milton Friedman, and is still prominent today.
Proponents of Neoliberalism see free markets and free trade
as a foundation for human flourishing, creating the most favorable conditions for
individual liberties, job growth, technological innovation and
transnational collaborations that promote peace and global prosperity.
They believe that government interference with free market systems promotes waste,
inefficiency, and stagnation.
They reject regulations on industries, high taxation, and
public services that are not subject to market competition, and
believe in shrinking the size of government and restricting its functions
to the protection of private property through policies and law enforcement,
the facilitation of global commerce, and the maintenance of a strong military.
Critics of Neoliberalism argue that Neoliberal policies exacerbate
rather than mitigate economic and social inequalities.
They cite the effects of unregulated capitalism and the reduction or
removal of safety nets typically provided by governments
to support those who are economically and socially vulnerable.
More fundamentally, many critics assert that Neoliberalism fails to account for
structural forms of violence such as systemic poverty, racism,
and other forms of discrimination.
They argue that these hinder equals access to the benefits of free
market capitalism that Neoliberals imply are universally shared.
By failing to acknowledge structural forms of oppression,
many Neoliberals assert that it is individual failings rather than
systemic inequality that lead to social and economic vulnerability.
As with other political and economic systems, religions function to both
support and challenge Neoliberalism in local, national, and global contexts.
[MUSIC]